good morning millennials happy thursday
welcome back to the morning toast
another wonderful episode of tmt hey
claude how are you doing with your
tick-tock faces
hey jackie happy thursday i'm doing
great how are you how's the belly how's
elsie
i'm doing i'm doing well it's been it's
been a hectic 12 hours because
bruno isn't feeling well and so when
bruno is not feeling well mom's not
feeling well and so i slept really badly
last night because i was just like
worried worried about brew i heard zach
taking him out i'm like things things
aren't going well for brew so i slept
really really badly and i'm just like
not a hundred percent myself but
the new episode of the redheads dropped
this morning and that is just giving me
such a joie de vivre we recorded it
yesterday
and i'm telling you we need to move the
podcast to the comedy section because
it's pure
it's pure comedy snatcher came out
swinging
because this book was if you read the
book or you've heard us talk about it
very different from what we've read in
the past and snatcher's not about that
life and so
it was just so funny so if you haven't
read the book definitely listen to the
pod and you're not going to read the
book definitely listen to the podcast
because it's just like funny and we
always recap the book so you'll know
what we're talking about if you plan on
reading the book or you're in the middle
of it finish it because we do spoil it
and then listen to the episode because
it's just
hysterical so that is giving me
some extra oomph this morning plus i
have my redheads mug so the first
thursday of every month it's really like
the first monday in may it's always
iconic and it's always a reason to get
up in the morning
well i have three things to say to what
you just said one okay
congratulations on the new episode
people the feedback i've been seeing is
rave
the second thing is back to bruno um i
do really feel like while i'm sad you
had a bad night's sleep like that is
exactly what type of sleep you're gonna
have for like the next couple months
like with the baby you're gonna be
worried so you know what maybe bruno can
feel like you you're impending labor and
he is going to train you as best as he
can that's what i think yep it's not
like i've been getting great sleep over
the last few weeks but i was just like
in a constant state of like half sleep
no half sleep half a week where was like
i was in la la land things weren't
making sense and i was just like
thinking of brew so today once we finish
this episode it's gonna be a chill zone
with bruno's sort of day i think i'm
gonna make him a nice pot of soup and
just rub his belly and tell him
everything's gonna be okay and he has
this heating pad
poor little bruno
bruno's goes through so much this man
carries so much like on his back and it
it manifests itself physically
yeah the third thing i wanted to tell
you just like kind of you know
made me think of it with the redheads so
i told you i started that book the
hating game that they turned into a
movie
only because like i kind of wanted to
watch a movie but i figured i might as
well read the book first and i honestly
like the first 10 no the first 30 like i
couldn't but then yesterday like i
really buckled down and like i was up
all night like i'm still not done i have
an hour left but like i'm obsessed
oh good
so that's the best feeling i haven't
been obsessed with a book in
in a few months honestly and
that's why i've been taking a break from
reading but what i did get back to last
night i finally i my pole dark break is
over i'm gonna watch the last season so
i started it last night and that's been
fun i like watching poldark before bed
because it's like the soundtrack is nice
and then it lives in my head while i'm
sleeping but i don't think this season
is gonna be it so for all the poldark
stands out there i think our days are
over but
it's something to watch
i did also um catch up i finished the
gilded age
because you know i i did kind of um
rail on it it's good it's definitely
good and honestly i'm here in
pennsylvania and so much of the
storyline
references and takes place in doyle's
town pennsylvania which is right by
where i am and i'm telling you like the
community is a blaze everyone's talking
about like their small little town being
referenced on this big hbo show so it's
very cool to feel like i'm a part of
something that is cool i why it takes
place in pennsylvania why did i think it
was new york it doesn't take place in
pennsylvania but there's a lot of
characters who come to new york from
doyle's town and they're just always
they shoot some stuff and you know at
the doylestown train station but they
talk about doyle's town quite a bit
okay very cool i still haven't gotten to
that but speaking of tv real housewives
of orange county was on last night so we
must recap it i have a good amount of
thoughts pretty good episode
yeah i thought it was an okay episode i
was like really struggling to keep my
eyes open to be honest but maybe that's
because i had two cocktails at dinner i
don't know it could be that i was
struggling to keep my eyes open too but
i had the busiest longest day yesterday
like it just did not stop even when i
went down for my nap i couldn't even
sleep i was just like i had so much
swirling around probably because of the
redheads you know the redheads are an
adrenaline boost and no and passion
projects are going to keep you up at
night for real
they are and until it's like edited
scheduled like it's just
always going to be top of mind for me
but the next episode of the redheads
will drop april 7th we are skipping the
month of march for my maternity leave so
next episode april 7th and it's a danish
choice and i always love a danish choice
even when you see what she chose and you
read the description you're like i don't
know if this is for me like dana never
misses really got it
yeah so that'll be a nice uh that'll be
a nice way to get back into the swing of
things
we've got a great show for y'all it's a
nice quiet thursday i feel like our
episodes this week have been like so
jam-packed like i watched so much tv at
the beginning of the week we had deer
toasters we have our new unburden
yourselves segment like it's just spit
and then there was the day where we lost
the first 30 minutes of our recording
like there's been a lot and i feel like
today is just gonna be a fun easy
episode fast five we've got a little tv
recap and i'm feeling like it's the
perfect you know agenda for a thursday
because i'm i'm very much living at the
weekend already i'm already there i've
been there since last weekend yeah
everything's been really jam-packed plus
it's like moody vibes outside today so
this is just gonna be like a for us you
know a chiller episode i guess but you
also never know what could happen on the
morning toast like one day you think we
have nothing to talk about and it's two
hour episode so you can't predict these
things but if i could i would say i feel
like we're just going to be some chill
girlies today
well i'm not like other girls tickets
available at girlwithnojob.comtour
um but also i want to say something kind
of crazy are you ready
and my life is kind of crazy i'm kind of
crazy
do you think today is a chilly day
i think depending on who you are and
where you are today is one thousand
percent of chilly day not for me
but
for you for sure
do you think that there's anywhere i can
find kosher ground beef ground turkey
ground chicken in new hope pennsylvania
you're asking the wrong person yeah is
who you're asking but you did have
kosher chicken well in the vlog brian is
so thoughtful like really so thoughtful
so he always has kosher chicken because
he knows like the only thing i eat is
like chicken and rice so he always says
kosher chicken maybe i could make like a
chicken chili does that is that a thing
no i don't know i don't know but what
about a chicken soup
we had chicken soup um two days ago i
literally feel like i'm in a retirement
facility like because me brian and john
are here we like work all day we don't
really see each other all day and then
we meet for lunch and during lunch john
who is brian's everyone knows him as
pasta on instagram he's an unbelievable
chef like really follow him on instagram
he does unreal recipes he had a soup
simmering all day on tuesday so we had
soup we had a stew on wednesday he's
really been taking care of us and so we
already did soup
damn brew needs that soup it was jackie
it was gorgeous like i was looking at
john i'm like are you jewish like this
is a jewish soup that sounds so good i
mean see what he can muster up with the
chili i think a chili would be great for
you i'm just like not in a chilly mood
taste buds wise i don't think i can
stand the time in the kitchen and i did
do too much chili in the fall i did i
over exposed myself to chili we now have
ourselves now i'm paying the price
because i can't enjoy on a beautiful
gloomy day like this no i know that's
why i brought it up but technically we
haven't had chili since the last time
you and i both like made too much chili
i haven't had chili in like months so i
think i actually might be ready for it i
think i'm gonna have to wait till next
season like for 20 22. yeah that's the
summer spring summer that's the kind of
break i need september joggers joggers
yeah
and that's my secret ingredient in my
chili recipe
joggers but i fully endorse anyone who
wants to make today a chili day there's
never it's never too late to make a
chili never and it's also never too late
to become a redhead which i think is a
common kind of misconception about our
brand and our show i think a lot of
people think like oh like i think it's
too late and i just think we should kind
of like clear that up you know what i'm
saying a hundred percent all of the
episodes are evergreen and we were
talking about it on the episode we're
skipping a month for myself
brian just brought me
he's such a good host just brought me a
starbucks grilled cheese he just left it
on the counter and i believe there's a
beverage of some sort
go check it out but you know that it's a
grilled cheese you know you'll be burned
at the stake if you try and eat on the
show no no i just saw him come into i'm
in the guest house and he dropped
something and he he literally went to
starbucks and got me grilled cheese like
such a good friend we have such podcast
eating trauma i wonder if other podcasts
like take it as seriously as we do we
did it once
remind me of the one time we did it i
don't recall i'll set the scene not to
trigger you
i remember it like it was yesterday
we were coming down from
coachella to la
we drove in the morning and then when we
arrived at our hotel we were gonna
podcast we were so [ __ ] hungry we
well actually there was two instances
but it was the same week because we were
traveling a lot we went from coachella
to la from la to las vegas and on both
of those travel days we hadn't eaten
before we started traveling and we
hadn't podcasted yet so when we arrived
to where we were getting to we
absolutely needed to eat and we
absolutely needed to podcast and we
thought we could do both at the same
time
big mistakes
huge god
jinx
so now we would never do that ever again
ever ever ever ever
so your grilled cheese will happen
what drink did he get you what drink no
there wasn't a drink i misspoke i
actually am sipping on some fresh
squeezed orange juice which is such an
underrated beverage and when it's cold
and it's just like it's a massage of the
esophagus
yum
yum yum
okay so i was just saying really quickly
for my maternity leave take the months
of the redheads off to go back and read
an old book that we've done and listen
to an old episode i don't know if
there's anyone out there and if you are
out there please reach out to me if you
are this person who has read every
single book and listened to every single
episode i don't think there's one person
but i would love to be proven wrong i do
no people are very selective people come
in and out you know that's true some
people don't want to try new genres if
this snitch oh my gosh snitch is not a
sugar fluid
do you um did you do today's wordle
no not yet i keep doing it later in the
day
me too but yesterday somebody spoiled it
for me so now it has to be the first
thing i do when i wake up and i didn't
get it
who would do such a thing
somebody okay so spoiler yesterday's
word
was moist and at like noon someone was
like are you triggered like that they
did the word moist i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me i didn't first of all
i didn't even i wasn't even talking
about wordle like i wasn't even
referencing or not referencing and they
just came out and sent me a dm and was
like
can you believe moist am i can i believe
you do you even have an issue with the
word moist
no i'm not one of those people like i
just want to say this about you trigger
an entire generation
not liking the word not liking the word
moist not a personality trait sorry
no i completely agree like one day
people woke up and decided to unite
against the word moist and it's really
like not that mad it's pretty
descriptive and i think that like if
you're still holding on to that trigger
then like it's pretty basic sorry
it's time to let go and let god
okay okay i think we've made enough
enemies
and now we can get into the past five
yeah
let's see how the rest of the show goes
[Laughter]
okay without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
modern fertility i've always been a big
fan of planning ahead you know
scheduling trips months in advance
plotting out my next career move
figuring out what i'm doing for dinner
while i'm still eating breakfast but i
never thought much about planning for
kids and that's why modern fertility was
created it's an easy and affordable way
to test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick mail it in
with a prepaid label and you'll get your
personalized results within 10 days
you'll get insight into your hormone
levels your ovarian reserve aka how many
eggs you have
and they also have a ton of other
important fertility factors the results
go deep into what every hormone means
and you can also talk one-on-one with a
fertility nurse to review your results
and your options for next step
traditional testing with your doctor can
cost over a thousand dollars but modern
fertility gets you the same information
at 159 dollars which is just a fraction
of the price and you can go to
modernfertility.com
toast to get 20 off that price so if you
have hsa or fsa you can put those
dollars towards modern fertility as well
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast and that
means your test will cost 139. instead
of the hundreds of thousands it would
cost at a doctor's office
again so get the 20 off your fertility
test when you go to modernfertility.com
toast modernfertility.com
thank you claudia and today's episode is
also brought to you by zoc doc no one
knows what you're looking for in a
doctor better than you and no one's
better at giving you the tools to find
the perfect doctor than zoc doc the
people who created sock doc found the
major pain points in health care all the
things that weren't working and they
said enough and they made booking a
great doctor surprisingly pain-free
so zocdoc is a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and are available when
you need them read up on local doctors
get verified patient reviews and see
what other humans had to say about their
visit so when you walk into a doctor's
office you're set up to see someone in
your network who gets you go to
zocdoc.com choose a time slot and
whether you want to see the doctor in
person or visit do a video visit just
like that you're booked i have to say
when i'm on tour and i have you know all
my mysterious ailments my rash zok dock
is an amazing resource when you're
traveling um because you can do like um
online video appointments and it's just
like so nice to know that if i'm not
home i can still get the care that i
need because you know i have like a lot
of problems
um it's super easy to find the doctors
that that is right for you and book an
appointment that works for your schedule
go to zoc doc dot com slash toast and
download the zocdoc app for free then
start your search with the top rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours so that's
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com toast zoc doc dot
com slash toast
great
before we dive in could we get a rash
update it's been a while okay so
it's actually been a journey like it was
healing very slowly but it was moving in
a positive direction
and then
like i guess that
like the middle of the bite which is
where i exactly was bitten like started
to become raised
and i was shook and then it became very
itchy
but
now it's just like a scab almost okay
i'll show you ready okay
oh it looks so much better oh i yeah
that little dot is where i was bitten
it's so much better you don't have that
like little square rash anymore though
so that's good no there's no
discoloration which is wonderful great
you'd love to see positive rash update
you really do
okay let's get into the stories our
first story we have time today
to talk about everyone's favorite couple
kanye and julia fox were celebrating her
birthday with her friends at lucian
despite the fact that
yeezy designer has been busy chatting up
kim kardashian lookalikes at the little
beach house in malibu this week yes i
didn't see that oh i did see that sorry
but she was right but it was confirmed
that she's just like a
co-working acquaintance
right but it was enough there have just
been many sightings on dumois of him
with other women yeah but then like
people were putting together who these
women were and like they're people who
like work with him and have been in his
like circle so it's not new news
anyways he flew back to new york on
wednesday to celebrate his newest muse's
32nd birthday yay flew into new york
city for her birthday and then is flying
back to la to finish his new album donda
they arrived together looking very
cuddly he was all smiles her friends
were also there it was a big group also
i saw that he gifted her and her friends
berkins
what yeah so her friends yeah they're
all like sitting there like posing with
perkins do you think she needs new
friends because i am available that's
the moral of this story
how to become friends but we'd have to
get in i mean now i think we missed the
birken so we'll have to come back for
the next birthday next birthday yeah but
we have a year to work on it
oh my god that is so crazy so i saw a
couple videos of their dinner and like
they're not in a private room or
anything there's just like so many
people at this table in this public
restaurant and there's like just people
literally crowding around them taking
videos it's extremely bizarre um
and i didn't realize that's what he had
gotten her i had seen that her birthday
was coming up and people online were
speculating like what he was gonna get
her like a car like something outrageous
um and honestly like a birkin is very
low key i'm not gonna lie
yeah a bergen for her like as a gift is
a you know
typical
celebrity gift but for all of her
friends
it must be nice i don't know why i feel
like her and liam mcsweeney are friends
did i make that up they i i believe liam
so no you didn't make that up they are
friends they've like podcasted together
and from what i understand liam
mcsweeney um was her sponsor
oh how is something
did she get a birkin i don't i didn't
see leah there but she deserves a birken
yeah
so anyways these two are going strong
they hadn't been together in um a minute
i guess now it's been like their one
month anniversary because they started
dating around new year's
yeah
and they're really doing it i mean they
were also at like fashion week in
all over world or whatever yeah
and
i guess this is here to stay
i mean i'm like fine with it i really am
i think of all the people
that kanye could have dated i think it's
nice that he's dating someone who
obviously loves the kardashians like she
doesn't want to fight with them you know
sometimes someone can bring a a spouse
into the family blac chyna who has an
obvious hatred of the family um so to
bring in a fan i don't know i'm kind of
here for it i do think a lot of like the
stuff that they do is really cringy
but overall of all the people who connie
could have dated post kim and knowing
kim is like so happy with pete i i don't
know i'm i'm fine with it now that i've
had some time to marinate with it some
of the [ __ ] they do is definitely like
rubs me in a bizarre way but that's not
a crime it's just cringy
yeah i agree also speaking of kim and
just being like she's so happy and
everything of the sort she got a plane
yeah
what she like i mean it hasn't been
confirmed but like she's been posting
like on her pj
and in a different way than like she
would normally post and it seems like
she hears it yeah it seems very like kkw
aesthetic like she was with her friends
natalie and olivia from wags and they
like had like a pj party on the pj for
natalie's birthday and i'm pretty sure
that she bought a plane well i've always
thought that it was incredibly
interesting that the kardashians as a
whole up until recently didn't have
their own plane i believe kylie has her
own now yeah yeah but they all just
charter which is like obviously rich
people problems and it's a difference
between you know a trip to mexico
costing 250 000
versus 30 million dollars so like i get
it um i just always thought it was weird
like how there isn't like a kardashian
hq plane but honestly they all travel so
much i don't even think one plane would
help them at all like they'd still need
to be chartering and then they also just
bought a 30 million plane so now that
kim is in the billionaires club
i think the timing is right but i've
always just thought it was really like
prudent of them to not have one because
they could afford it yeah and i just
want to say it's not verified that like
that was her plan but i was just getting
like plain vibes from her
and ownership vibes i'm getting
ownership vibes and earlier this week it
was reported that schemes is now valued
at 3.2 billion dollars so it's not just
like she hit the billion mark and no
she's ascending and maybe she's taking
flight in her new private jet
i would be so happy for her and i was
really um i felt i was shepping a lot of
nachos when that wall street journal
valued her at
three point something billion for skims
because honestly skims is the greatest
company that's ever walked the earth and
everything i own from them just is
fabulous
and they deserve
i think like do you think at this point
they're bigger than spanx
i don't know i don't know the numbers
and i can only say it like based on like
what i see and what i feel but like i
don't follow sarah blakely and i do
follow kim kardashian so like skims is
all over
my feed and my life and spanx isn't okay
this article that i just pulled up from
2021 said that spanx is valued at 1.2
billion which would mean skims is three
times as large
interesting but actually
i don't know is that what sarah
blakely's worth or the company you know
yeah i don't know i i think
i don't i mean spanx is like still the
word for shapewear you know no in 2021
the announcement came after a huge
investment from blackstone meaning the
company's worth has skyrocketed to 1.2
billion
in 2021 after a big investment but also
skims is a lot more like apparel than
shapewear these days you know it's not
just so is spanx by the way
yeah i guess i wear spanx leggings
everyone does like i think some of their
best selling items are no longer even
like their control top pantyhose it's
their people are obsessed with their
leggings they make like cute sweaters
and [ __ ]
yeah very true
very interesting i mean there's
there's enough to go around for everyone
and you know what's so interesting like
business-wise is what's always been so
impressive about spanx is like not only
the growth of the company but also the
fact that
the the word of the name of the brand
has become a word like that
underneath like
it's a word for [ __ ] that's i was saying
that when you were looking it up like it
is the word for shapewear it's like oh i
apologize
it's like a band-aid
yeah
and you know what i do think skims like
is on its way to being there like i
could i haven't ever said it but i could
see myself being like you have any skins
on under there
yeah but schemes mean so many things now
it's pajamas well i think the olympics
are life-changing and
i think their pajamas seriously should
win a nobel peace prize i'm being dead
[ __ ] serious
i can't wear them right now because the
waistbands are too tight for me but uh
they are quite delicious also how often
i need to start a tracker for how often
she does drops because the drugs are
coming and they don't stop coming like
what is the cadence every two weeks or
is it once a month and it just like
feels like more frequent than that it's
every day
but it's also like restocks of other
ones but yes i agree they do they have
so much inventory like so many
drops and just so many ideas for like
new vibes and collections
it's really an idea cotton ribbed
yeah
it's an idea factory
well speaking of the kardashians our
next story is an unverified rumor that
is most likely false and came from doom
1 and dumas also said not true it's
false
it's worth talking about
we need to talk there's literally no way
i know but like there's where do people
come up with stuff like this
khloe kardashian
like
sorry has been linked to harry jowzy
from too hot to handle according to
dumas who has since then said someone
else responded that this is absolutely
not true but this is what dumas said one
of my closest friends works at a very
well-known pr agency in la and it's
confirmed that khloe kardashian and
howie jowzy harry jowzy are talking
apparently they've been dming back and
forth and texting and then last night he
picked up a bentley in flowers just to
drive them to her house
no okay
this is not true but let's just play
pretend like it is true okay yeah um
i just want
chloe to be happy
and you know what i do think
harry jowzy like was on too hot to
handle like as a certified [ __ ] boy
but i followed him like
a little bit in his recent fame on tick
tock and stuff and he does a podcast he
actually seems like not like a [ __ ] boy
he actually seems like a nice guy so if
this were to be true like i actually do
think him and chloe like he could make
chloe temporarily happy not long term
but i i agree i could see him making
chloe temporarily happy i do think he's
probably like the ultimate [ __ ] boy like
just everything about him he was a
fuckboy before he got famous and now
he's like so famous and he's so handsome
and like everyone's falling over him but
i agree with you there's something about
him like as a businessman that's
extremely legitimate and like he's
parlayed his career into like something
that's uh
here to stay sort of respectable yeah
and like the and it's hard to be a
podcaster you know so like his podcast
pops telling me you're telling me
so i
i'm like i
this is probably not true
but a part of me like hopes it is and
that chloe's just having some fun with a
handsome man
who like will make her laugh and make
her smile
i feel like all the kardashians are like
taking a page out of courtney's book
like because what happened to courtney
is so like freak and it's not someone
you would expect her to be with and then
just over time like they started to make
each other really happy and make a lot
of sense and that's like kind of
happening with kim and pete and maybe
chloe wants one you know a skinny tall
man for herself
yes except just to back it up like
travis barker is an extremely serious
per like person and a serious
suitor and when he was like he's the
same age as courtney they have like a
long-standing friendship i think like
then kim took that and and
did her own spin on it her own version
but it's not apples to apples because
like travis is husband material
and
harry jowzy is not travis barker
no but it's like okay so i just feel
like it's a watered-down version it goes
like travis yes pete harry josie yes
yeah but i i'm just like i'm here for it
even though i do think at the end of the
day like mj said chloe needs an
accountant but she's obviously not ready
i also believe this is fraudulent
right and no she's not ready she needs a
businessman bow
needs a businessman though like
get back to the golf course at some
point
and meet someone i love chloe so much
and i want her so badly to have like a
really good healthy relationship and i
feel like she has not had that
but we also just need to talk about her
like bad taste in men
um
yeah
like
yeah
yeah i want her to be happy like let
help me help you
yeah and i think harry jowzy is not
not
but where does [ __ ] like this come from
then if there's no truth to it like
where does it come from
but that's what celebrities are always
saying like when you hear their
documentaries they like read stuff about
themselves that is so far-fetched and
sometimes they say like no like the
rumors are true and sometimes they say
like
the the way that like these random
rumors come out of nowhere with people
i've never met is so crazy and i really
actually do feel like this is one of
those situations
yeah okay i feel that i just thought it
was worth discussing uh the possibility
because it's like hysterical and it's
fun to dream and it's fun to dream
exactly and maybe i feel like sometimes
this could happen too where it's like
okay two people who don't know each
other but then like someone says they're
dating so like chloe's googling harry
jowzy and she's like wait why wouldn't i
want him to come over with bentley and
flowers maybe he dm's her and sends her
the doom wah thing and is like lol and
she's like lol want to come over and no
watch him literally
this could bring them together
[Laughter]
it's just
i agree
you know what it sounds like the premise
of that new jlo movie which looks
horrible but also really good called
marry me which i can't wait to see it
looks horrible but also really good
it looks horrible but i will be waiting
in line when the clock strikes midnight
to see it in theaters
yeah
honestly and i ship owen wilson and j.lo
just want to say horde
horde
so
okay
hard
speaking of ships are you ready for our
next story which is an update from a
question that you asked yesterday ask
and you shall receive
if it's a story that's an update from
the question that i asked yesterday
that's brought to you by thread up yes
yes yes
did you guys know that by choosing one
garment instead of a new a worn garment
instead of a used one you can save 77
gallons of water thread up an online
consignment and thrift store is working
to do the planet good and give life to
like new clothing
thredup is one of the largest online
thrift stores where you can save up to
ninety percent off estimated retail you
get insane deals of of thrifting with
the convenience of online shopping with
over two million like new items to shop
and thousands of new arrivals daily it's
the best place to shop for your wallet
and for the planet you can customize
your search by size style and budget so
you can find the best deals and more for
more than 35 000 brands like banana
republic madewell nike and taylor loft
thredup also has an easy return policy
so they make thrifting worry-free so
thrifting is actually like a
back-breaking endeavor like if you want
to go out and thrift and first of all
thread up is just so premium the website
makes it really easy to search for
things in your size you can categorize
by brand and they have really nice
brands like nice way nicer than you
would expect and it's also just great
for the planet so there's really no
reason not to do it because we're all
shopping online and why not throw into
our rotation a good sustainable
online thrift store like thredup
thredup is offering a deal just for new
customers so right now head to
thredup.com and get an additional get up
to an additional 50 off plus free
shipping on your first order so that's
up to an extra 50 off plus free shipping
on your first order just by heading to
thredup.com t-h-r-e-d-u-p-dot-com
for up to 50 off and free shipping on
your first order
sweet okay are you ready for our next
story which is an answer to a question
you asked yesterday yes
love is blind season two trailer drops
right after claudia asks where is love
is blind season 2 and the show will be
back on netflix on february 11th with an
all new group of single hopefuls from
chicago who will attempt to find love in
the pods and get engaged sight unseen
was last time chicago or was it atlanta
atlanta mm-hmm yeah so new city very
exciting i love the fact that like it's
very
geographically focused that doesn't make
it so that like we can't not be together
because of a long-distance relationship
um did you watch the trailer what do you
think are you so excited
i am like i really didn't expect to fall
so head over heels in love with the show
the first time around like i thought it
was so
dumb
um and now here we are like years later
we have two married couples right amber
and barnett and the king and queen of
love is blind the hamiltons um so
i'm very excited i love this show i fell
in love with it the first time i saw it
i hope that
like the show got so big and all those
people got so famous and so when that
happens you just open yourself up to a
pool of candidates who apply for the
show who are totally in it for the wrong
reasons and that was the beauty of love
is blind was that like everyone was so
earnest they didn't even know this was
gonna be on netflix they had no idea
their lives were about to change in the
way that they did
so i'm like i'm a little worried i hope
that they
can do good casting because in my
opinion the success of the show the
first time around was due large in part
to the casting
i agree that's definitely a cause for
concern but even the first time around
like anyone they know it's a reality
show there's always the chance that like
people are going on tv they're not
afraid of the fame
so
i'm sure they were also very discerning
about this season
and it looks like they have a really
nice group of people looks like we've
got engagements weddings runaways
everything that we can look forward to
and i'm excited because that was like a
fun time that was you know probably the
last good time before the pandemic was
watching love is blind and maybe it'll
take us back to another good time yeah
like the way we all just like rallied
around you know jessica being 34 and
mark being 24 like there was just so
much good stuff and like so many memes
that like made me giggle so loud like i
loved that time in my life and i'm very
much looking i know you you can't go
home again i know that but i am looking
forward to at least trying to make the
journey back home one more time right
and i think unlike other reality shows
it had a lot of heart and
it was pretty deep considering like the
premise which is that you don't know
what someone looks like you have to fall
in love with them just based on
conversations and i'm really into that
you know i think that banter should be a
real app and that people should go on
dates with other people not knowing what
they look like i'm here for it
i also think the show was like so
successful because as like a as an
audience people who watch dating shows
like we were so like we've had it up to
here with the bachelor like you know two
hour episodes with like 35 seconds of
substantial conversations really no
depth so much filler and love is blind
was the complete opposite not one filler
scene like everything was just deep and
emotional getting to know everyone and
it was like the exact opposite of the
bachelor which is really what we needed
at the time yeah i agree and i hope that
that's what we get again me too so i'm
happy for you season two is coming
february 11th i'll definitely be
watching i hope they last time they like
released all the episodes except for
like the weddings right and then we were
all tuning in episodically correct it
was like three at a time but if you came
in on like the third
batch right then you had all of them
except for the finale and then we all
watched the finale like together
remember we were like scrambling to
watch it on the planet mm-hmm yeah
good times so good
okay ready for our next story some sweet
bev ben news
nikki have never been has debuted her
baby bump nikki hilton has announced
that she is pregnant she says the best
thing in life
comes in threes she captioned the
stunning sickening photo of her in a
self-portrait dress with a little bump
she's so elegant like it's just not fair
actually that girls like nikki hilton
walk around and we have to walk around
like right next to them you know a
thousand percent also some more bump
news was that rihanna posted her bump
obviously like we had the confirmation
but she hadn't posted any of the
pictures yet and she posted uh like a
selfie of her bump and some of the
walking photos that they took earlier
this week yeah no it's like a gorgeous
time to be pregnant
gorgeous gorgeous oh yeah and add nikki
to the club and also lauren bostic is
pregnant again oh yeah
that's exciting i'm feeling really
surrounded by like really cool women
chic women mm-hmm
it's happy for you the group is getting
bigger i thought when people started to
like have their babies that like my
pregnancy you know
padres would it was just dwindle i
didn't even think about the people who
would announce in the next
weeks yeah no and actually a lot of
people just gave birth obviously raven
and adam gave birth um ashley ikennetti
and jared gave birth
yes unclear on kylie but i assume maybe
she's still pregnant i don't know
ah
i'm sure it's
maybe she's still pregnant but i'm sure
it's like any day now yeah
and it's so very close to stormy's
birthday
right it's just a gorgeous time to be a
woman
in
utero
no that's not right not the woman's not
in utero the kid is yeah well it's also
a gorgeous time to be a fetus in utero
yes it's it must be nice in there
nice and warm totally
i think that like because i love my bed
so much i would love being in utero
because you love sleep right womb tings
yeah you sleep except for like the times
when you're just like punching to get
out and you also eat in there
you um you hiccup a lot by the way you
do how do you give do you have to get
food
umbilical core follicle cord yep
is that real
so you chew your food it goes down your
belly through your
organs
and
then to the umbilical cord into the
baby's stomach yep i'm pretty sure
wow that is like so crazy
the baby also just baby drinks in like
with their mouth
sometimes on the sonogram you'll see the
fluid from the yeah like
yeah
baby that's gross
listen baby's got a drink okay baby's
thirsty
who understands better baby's got a
drink i understand
how fascinating
yeah it's fascinating stuff the the
human body
are you concerned at all like about your
vagina
um definitely have concerns for sure but
there's it's out of my control like i'm
trying not to worry about that which i
can't control and it's pretty like cool
to go through this experience you know
just like thousands of women before me
and see what all the fuss is about
because it's like childhood it's
actually so true childbirth is like the
most pain like a person
will look like an experience will likely
experience it's like is it a child birth
level so it's like what is that level of
pain i'll find out oh my god that sounds
[ __ ] horrible i really though
appreciate your like positive spin on it
and what's my other option
i guess yeah no you're going to do
epidural right yes that's the plan
so it's not it's actually like i'm not
connected to my my female ancestors from
through the pain years ago yeah they're
like girl yeah because they were doing
it like rocks
sit down
literally
and just really quickly before we finish
up this conversation um you're 100 sure
you don't want me in there right
i'm 100 sure i feel like i actually
would be like extremely helpful like i
would get you a fan i would like you
know get everyone out of your way i
would crack a joke bring a snack like i
don't know i just i would think about it
okay
yeah i just feel like i want i'm not
trying to make the most of it or like
have like laughter and memories i'm just
trying to get through
and like tunnel vision till the end you
know
okay but i but i do just want to be like
explicitly clear while you do not want
me in the room you will have no choice
but to be in my room okay
oh wow well i mean these days you can
only have two people in the room with
you
so it would be i don't care i'll give
birth literally in someone's backyard
okay a home birth
honestly you should give birth we've
never
you should give birth in the tub
that's a full circle for my brand i'm so
you
totally i love that um okay are you
ready for our fifth and final story
i am i really am do you is it something
to sing about
maybe tomorrow for friday maybe you'll
be feeling yourself yeah
um our fifth and final story is really
crazy will also lead into oc recap but
elizabeth lynn vargas has been
traumatized after her ex barricaded
himself in her home
so her manager told page six that she's
shaken up and had an extremely traumatic
experience fortunately the newport
police department saved her and she's
doing well sources uh close to the
former real houses of new orange county
star told page six that elizabeth vargas
called the police on tuesday after her
unnamed ex whom she had been seeing on
and off for the last few months began to
extort her
quote he became obsessive with her would
show up at places and come by her house
randomly he asked her for money all the
time so she gave him a little money but
then
he started threatening to extort her she
called the police yesterday so police
started monitoring the house and he
shows up he runs in the house holds her
hostage has a gun when police realized
he pulled a gun out they raided the
house she's traumatized my team showed
up yeah she's traumatized they said she
was held captive
and she has yet to address the incident
but this is traumatizing yeah well a lot
of the toasters were talking about this
in one of the facebook groups and i was
reading the comments because a lot of
them live in oc and they were like
it was [ __ ] crazy like so many cops
like the whole block was shut down so it
was like this enormous deal i saw videos
it was like a full-blown hummer swat
team showing up to elizabeth lynn
vargas's beach home like it was shocking
um that is crazy and to be clear this is
not the ex-husband the billionaire who
she was talking about on the show she's
been dating someone somewhat recently
well it's it's completely unclear it
could be any ex from any amount of time
before
i um it's probably not her ex-husband
but it's not clear who who this x is and
when they were x's from
interesting well this is the craziest
story
um she's not a housewife anymore so like
i don't know what sort of
details we're gonna get from her but she
after her her real housewife servitude
she has been extremely public like i
think she's told everyone she's getting
her own tv show like she cares about the
fans and so i do believe we'll be
getting an in-depth analysis on what
went down yeah and i know that brian is
like her number one fan yeah so we were
freaking out yeah i hope that you know
ryan's home is fully stocked with vargas
vodka he says it's very good
i didn't know she had a varga is it new
i don't think so it's like it's
something she's had for a while it's
gorgeous bottle like really gorgeous hmm
interesting yeah check it out
okay
i'm wishing her the best seriously like
that's so [ __ ] scary yeah beyond men
are so nuts like my god
nuts
like what are you doing
i don't know
get a life
um okay well that's a great um segue
into the oc housewives recap in our tv
recap segment which is brought to you by
catalina crunch
if you're trying to eat better catalina
crunch cereal has the crunch you crave
without the empty carbs it's absolutely
delicious i'm a cereal girlie like i
love cereal but it's so sugary like it's
just
so unnecessarily like out of control and
catalina crunch is
sensational like really good cereal and
like most zero sugar food doesn't taste
delicious but catalina crunch has really
really nailed it it's zero sugar low
carb keto friendly and it has a whopping
11 grams of plant-based protein and nine
grams of fiber per serving so you could
taste it for yourself and understand why
over ten thousand customers rate
cannalita crunch five stars they've got
eight crave worthy flavors to choose
from and they have a lot of nostalgic
ones like cinnamon toast decadent dark
chocolate and creamy chocolate peanut
butter the cinnamon toast is a personal
favorite of mine and if you're not sure
which flavor to try first that's what
the variety pack is for it's gluten-free
grain-free non-gmo and it has only real
clean ingredients nothing artificial
you can see why catalina crunch cereal
is the fastest growing cereal brand in
america just go to catalinacrunch.com
toast for 15 off your first order plus
free shipping that's catalinacrunch.com
toast and again if you're not sure which
flavor to start with try the variety
pack and check out their delicious
cookies and snack mixes while you're at
it
catalinacrunch.comtoast for 15 off your
first order plus free shipping that ad
just made me so hungry i've been on such
a cereal kick
in the last few months and now once we
hang up i'm going to make myself a bowl
of catalina crunch thank you it's the
[ __ ] catalina wine mixer like i don't
know what i've been trying to tell these
people for sale it's the catalina crunch
mixer yes okay real housewives of oc we
wrapped up our trip in mexico no we
didn't we're still there but it's a last
night no no and next week is like more a
little bit more of mexico plus we go
back they didn't say that it was the
last night
i don't think so i don't know why i
literally heard someone say that okay
well we're continuing our trip in oc um
noella has this like out of body exp all
have this like crazy experience i would
never do a sweat lodge like i just want
to say i would literally rather be dead
like i can't no also like jen summed it
up best like they're all hungover yes
they're all dehydrated and noella's
going through emotional distress like
this is a recipe for disaster and noella
didn't eat last night remember she made
like a whole thing that she wasn't
eating so she hasn't eaten in hours like
what who the [ __ ] thought that was a
good idea no like a really really
terrible idea to be hungover and do a
sweat lodge like that just
nothing about it was surprising can i
tell you how much like sympathy i have
in my heart for what dr jen was going
through like
first like being away from home and
being in pain
there's nothing worse and like this is a
new group of friends and yes her and
heather have really connected but like
you don't want to go to someone's room
crying my leg it's like i totally get it
i felt
so bad for her when she was on the
treadmill like talking to ryan who was
just being like an [ __ ] like
like yes i know that it's my fault
because i forgot to do my workout and i
went to see the homes that like i my leg
is in pain but like that's not what you
need to hear when you're literally in
like agonizing pain i would literally
have divorced him on the spot like dead
ass no i literally was like thinking
about how i could cry watching this
scene like the despair that she's in and
she's getting [ __ ] nothing from that
good for nothing loser loser and we see
in like future episodes and scenes that
like he's gonna shape up to be an even
bigger [ __ ] loser so just like
knowing that she's just married to a
loser and she's in pain and she's
carrying the weight of the world on her
shoulders and this man can't even send
her a sympathetic word i was just like i
was heartbroken for her and
even though she's like kind of
irrelevant to the rest of the show i
love
i have a warm place in my heart for her
because like that is an extremely low
feeling
and i actually thought the conversation
at dinner before things went sideways
between dr jen and heather was like
really interesting just like with two
women with like two opposing roles in
the home just giving each other advice i
thought it was like really sweet and i
actually really like the friendship
between heather and jen and heather like
liking jen makes me like jen a little
bit more um and i just thought that was
like a really mature conversation like
heather very much is like the the home
she's the home unlock and and terry very
much is like the financials and her and
jen are totally opposite
and i actually thought she gave jen
really good advice agreed the problem is
ryan is no heather ryan is no heather
and then things go sideways at the
dinner and noella's just like impossible
to root for i do believe that she had no
idea that
the um card game was so vulgar like i do
believe she just typed into amazon like
great gift for bisexual person like i do
believe that's how it happened but the
fact that like she now learned that
that's not the gift
the gift wasn't appropriate like just be
like oh my god i had no idea i'm so
sorry like the end she just drags
everything out because she's like too
proud to just acknowledge any wrongdoing
yeah and like
unfortunately for her like in this
situation heather is extremely right and
noella just like has it out for heather
and just doesn't want to concede to her
in general so she's just like
withholding an apology that should be
forthcoming really easily because like
you [ __ ] up and it's not a big deal
and you have a perfectly logical
explanation you just like won't say what
you need to say to get yourself out of
it and you're like digging your heels
and you're making yourself look crazy
awful yeah and when heather got like
choked up because i don't know why
noello just basically like went to a
place where she was not outright but
just kind of implying like you know
heather's very stuck up and she does not
understanding of like the lgbtq plus
lifestyle when heather got choked up and
being like i have multiple gay children
and i support them and i love them like
i felt really bad for heather like i
thought that put heather in a bad spot
when heather has made it very clear like
she fully supports her children so much
so she got the kids book published she
had the book like i think like that was
just like an uncool spot to try and put
heather and she handled it well a low
blow and she was clear when noelle was
clearly backed into a corner and thought
she could like really i don't know bury
heather with that and i'm glad that
heather didn't take that sitting down
and just like uh let noella trash talk
her like that and it was
so uncalled for and you know what i
wasn't mad that emily told noella she
was a pity invite because like i thought
she knew
right i mean the thing is she wasn't a
pity invite heather didn't invite her
because she felt bad for her she had to
be cooper
she was invited as a favor but like what
about this is facts you you knew you
weren't invited at one point and then
you got invited
now you just know it was gina who asked
if you could come like it's really not a
big deal now you know it's cheetah who
advocated on your behalf who you've been
so mean to the whole weekend like when
noella and shannon were like just trying
to make something happen at the dinner
the night before and then the next night
like keep that thing going versus gina
and emily like don't like seriously
don't you're doing you think you're
doing something you're not the three of
them have had like an extremely
intense day where they're at it this
dinner is three different people than
the dinner before so it's like why do we
need to bring up stuff from the dinner
last night like we've we are on another
level shannon honestly is so irrelevant
when she was screaming to be heard
because no one was listening to her i
was like why should they listen to you
and then she finally got the floor and
she didn't say anything she said
she said like exactly what other people
were saying i thought she was going to
come with like the solution you know
that profound and she just like said
more of the same i was like girl bye
no jackie she's so irrelevant like when
they were all
looking at homes and she like kept
getting off the bus and her dress kept
like blowing up i kept forgetting she
was there like she really
in a very weird way has and i wouldn't
of all the women like this new group
merging with the old group if i would
have had to guess like who would have
fallen through the cracks i might have
said like emily
i honestly never would have said gina
cause gina's only one who actually knows
heather from years back she's
slipping through the cracks she's so
what about you said gina
he said gina i
i would have suspected it might have
been emily i never would have suspected
it would have been shannon because
shannon has known
heather for the longest shannon's like
really like the og of the group now and
she's just like crazy like she always
finds her way into the drama she's
having the hardest time she needs a map
she cannot find the drama
yeah i feel like she's gonna realize
this soon and then start like swinging
in all directions and and actually like
not like becoming the drama but not in a
way that's productive at all and i i can
see herself writing herself off this
show
because there's just yeah
unintentionally yeah
and i would be fine with that you know
the scene
the scene with the husbands which like
was giving me nothing like i'm all for
husbands becoming main characters it
works on jersey this was nothing of the
sort um but when like dr jenn found out
that like ryan wasn't invited like i
actually felt really bad and it was like
super awkward but nobody's met ryan have
they because he doesn't like come to
anything because he's i think they have
at heather's book party oh no he wasn't
there
yeah so like you know you're right they
haven't met him the other men have met
each other
and ryan is just beyond irrelevant
yeah i agree i hate like
and it's not new jersey and it's not
utah
no but the conversations that they're
having like you know when are john and
shannon gonna get married why why do
they need to get married like they both
have kids they've both been married for
so long they had bad divorces like why
can't they just be happy partners who
own a home one day like what is with all
this like late in life marriage that's
[ __ ] like 25 year olds do like why who
needs to be married after all you've
been through like why is it not enough
just to be in a good relationship like
totally dolores
yeah
yeah i mean i understand
except gina except gina like gina really
she's in her 30s like gina cannon should
get married again gina's not shannon
like the no it's two different
conversations
yeah
yeah um so yeah it was a cute episode
also so i watch watch what happens live
it was um
who the [ __ ] was on from oh gina and
larsa pippen from miami
and i saw the commercial of them coming
out i oh the commercial was really
awkward i haven't watched miami yet i
haven't watched miami yet um
and i'm going to and i just like never
aside from that one episode where she's
like fighting with courtney's friend
sarah uh when they all go on vacation in
kardashians i don't really know larsa i
don't think i watched season one of real
housewives of miami which was the only
season that she was on so i just like
i don't know larson i just know her now
as being like kim's former friend
but i was
loving her personality and watch what
happens
i'm kind of a larsa stan i need to watch
miami and i'm going to do that when um
maybe this weekend or something just
when i want to treat myself to something
like that apparently it's amazing
everyone's saying the best things about
it but i was just like loving larsa so
much she's so cute she was being like
funny she was giving like pretty good
tea but also like withholding a lot but
even when she was like i'm not answering
something it was like that's an answer
in itself of course like andy asked
about like kim and pete kim
yeah and i just like really wasn't
expecting to kind of fall in love with
larsa and watch what happens because
usually it's a place people go like it's
hard to come off really well even if
you're like the most funny personable
person you only get like such small
sound bites that it's really hard to
make a splash and i was just like really
impressed with how she just held herself
and i hoped that um
i hope that you know her and kim can
find their way back to each other well
do you know that real housewives
ultimate girls trip is gonna start
premiering on bravo like now
episodically week to week um
so
i wonder if they're gonna do the same
thing with miami
i don't know but they also filmed a
miami reunion already
no way yeah so it's the real deal maybe
it will come
who [ __ ] needs that episodically [ __ ]
we've seen on peacock
no i don't understand like if it's a
peacock original just leave it on
peacock i guess if it's in the time slot
that wasn't being taken by anything and
not everybody who has cable has peacock
like there will be a handful of people
who would watch it and if there's not
anything else they were going to program
into it then what's
oh the downside the best part of theresa
judice last night on no two nights ago
on watch weapons live was andy asking
her stuff about ultimate girls trip and
being like were you surprised that
cynthia like was really not able to make
a connection with any of the women and
teresa was like what are you talking
about like she became friends with
everyone and andy was like i'm gonna ask
you a question and like you have to
promise to be honest did you watch the
show which was such a good question
because what are you talking about
literally the biggest takeaway from the
show was that cynthia like took the
biggest loss she made no friends her and
kenya broke up like and and she was like
yeah i watch it and he was like did you
only watch the scenes that you were in
he she said no but she definitely didn't
watch it it didn't even occur to me
until andy asked that yeah i can't
imagine not watching and also of course
you want to watch the scenes that you're
in like just to see yourself but
wouldn't you want to see the whole thing
just to see what was going on in other
rooms like when what people are saying
about you
yeah
i i can't i don't know i guess when
you've been on tv for so long like you
really can't right be expected to watch
everything and i think also if you watch
everything like it really makes you
probably like crazy like for the next
season you're just like constantly
thinking maybe sometimes maybe in order
to be a good reality star like you
really can't watch you just have to live
well
it's possible andy also asks teresa on
the post show
if her and louis are getting a prenup
and it was the most awkward thing i've
ever seen in my whole entire life it's
clear that they haven't had the
conversation they haven't had the
conversation with gia chiming in from
the bar
um it was
really
it was really painful to see
do you think
who do you think has more money
tree or louis tree
theresa but he has like a real estate
company now
he does
yeah j frank italia junior works for him
works for louie oh okay so it's like
there's actual work to be done
right um
i would still say teresa
yeah
yeah i don't know
um
so it was a good episode of oc
that's it for the tv recap right there's
nothing on tonight
nothing on tonight i'll get back to
poldark and now i'm feeling real
housewives of miami i need to i need to
see about this larsa yeah me too you
just kind of made me want to i want to
finish my book today and also watch how
like i'll watch it and she's like the
worst villain but i don't know i just
really i
i felt something good you have a way of
like being drawn to people who everyone
hates
a hundred it's like your first time yeah
no i and i i'm fine with that you're
just not like other girls
not at all um so that's our show you
guys thank you so much for listening we
hope you all have a great day and we'll
see you tomorrow thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
rate of cast box all the places where we
listen to the podcast find us morning
just leave a five star review about a
beautiful stunning and smart we are
instagram update we are still working on
it and we actually are it just will take
a long time and we can explain to you
guys like what went down afterwards but
we are working on it
it will come it will come back there's
just like a million things we need to do
before we and we're all over it just
like i'm not making this up like it is
coming back 1 000 that's exactly what's
going on and we'll let you know
everything that's going on once we have
it back
and in the meantime follow us on our
personal accounts so that you can be
kept abreast with all things tmt
goodbye love ya goodbye everyone